getting information out of Iran is
almost impossible for Outsiders at the
moment
yeah so these pictures which have never
been seen before were filmed in secret
at Masa amini's grave earlier this week
the day was an important one it would
have been her 23rd birthday
[Applause]
in the mountainous border region between
Iran and neighboring Iraq we met with
massa's cousin the family asked him to
speak to us because they can't
foreign
[Music]
was arrested by Iranian morality police
in the capital Tehran for not wearing
her headscarf properly Iranian police
say that she died of natural causes in
custody but her cousin says that is not
true
um
foreign
Masa amini was Kurdish a minority group
mostly living in Western Iran
but really significantly her killing has
caused an uprising across the entire
country there are protests in almost
every Iranian Province now and they have
been violent
it's hard to know exactly how many
people have been killed by Iranian
police in the Crackdown
but anywhere between 35 and 50 seems
likely and there will be more
foreign
[Applause]
the Iranian regime is now facing the
biggest protests for years against its
Hardline rule
the president Ibrahim raisi has blamed
conspirators and ominously said the
protests will be dealt with decisively
but if this started with the death of
one young woman It's Quickly spread to
be a rebellion against repression across
Iranian Society
the name Masa amini is now their
rallying Cry For Change Alice bunkel Sky
News in Iraqi Kurdistan